- [Instructor] In several
videos we have talked already
about the price elasticity of supply.
In this video, we're going
to dig a little bit deeper,
and we're going to think about
what factors might make a supply curve,
or supply schedule, or portions of it,
to be more elastic or inelastic.
So we'll think about the
determinants of the price
elasticity of supply.
And to help us think about that,
I've drawn two different supply curves.
And so, remember, price
elasticity is thinking about
how sensitive is the quantity,
or the price elasticity
of supply, we're thinking about
how sensitive is a percent
change in quantity supplied
to a percent change in price.
So, for example, if we were to go from
this price, to this price,
it's a pretty significant
percent change in price.
It looks like about a 50% change in price.
But if we look at this supply curve,
where it's getting pretty vertical,
it's not quite vertical yet,
but it's getting pretty steep,
our percent change in quantity
is going from here to here,
so it's not as dramatic.
So these parts of the curve
that are relatively steep,
as they're approaching
more and more vertical,
we would consider those to
be relatively inelastic.
If you had a perfectly vertical,
or portions of this curve
that were perfectly
vertical, at those portions
you would say that you
have perfect inelasticity.
And then, if on the other
hand, in this example,
if we were to change our price from say,
this to this, that's a relatively small
percent change in price,
but notice it could result
in a fairly large percent
change in quantity supplied,
we're going from this to this.
So, when we are more
horizontal, or the flatter our
supply curve is, that would be,
we're talking about relative
elasticity, or we are
much more elastic here
than we are there.
So, elastic.
And if you were perfectly horizontal,
then you would have a perfectly elastic
part of our supply curve,
or our supply schedule.
Now what would cause, what
are the factors that would
make us get more
inelastic, or more elastic?
Well let's think about a situation,
let's say we are in this world.
Let's say we are in the
world, starting at this price,
where this is our quantity.
Imagine that the factories
that produce whatever good
we're talking about here, they're already
at full production.
And to make more production
would take a lot of time,
or there might not even be the resources
to have more production.
Maybe the people who make the factories
are doing other things right now.
Maybe you have other
resources, other inputs,
into your production that
there's just not more of.
Maybe oil, as much oil in
the world is being produced,
and that's an input into our production.
And so in that world,
even if the price is,
even if the price goes dramatically up,
people might want to
produce a lot more quantity,
but they just can't, they
don't have more factories,
or they don't more inputs to produce them.
So, the quantity might go up a little bit,
they might run the factory,
they might run the factories
in overtime, or the people who
are trained to do that skill,
and maybe there just
aren't a lot more people
who can do that skill,
they're working overtime,
but they can't produce a lot more.
And so, a couple of
things that we can glean
from that example is, this
inelasticity of supply
tends to happen in the short run,
when in the short run, you're
not gonna be able to build
a new factory in the short run.
You're going to be able
to find more sources of
let's say oil in the short run.
You're not going to be able
to train a lot more people
to produce a lot more, in the short run.
So if we're talking about a supply curve
that's describing more of
a short run time frame,
then it tends to be more inelastic,
and then the other
thing is, and we already
talked about this is, there's
not available resources,
or not a lot of available
resources, not a lot
of available,
available resources.
Once again, your factory's
operating full-out.
You've hired everyone who
can produce that thing
you're producing, or some natural resource
that you need as an
input, to make this good,
well, the world is already
producing as much as they could.
Well, let's then go to
the other situation.
What would cause elasticity?
Well, this could be a world where
in the long run, it might be
easier to get more resources.
In the long run, you can
build more factories.
You can find and hire
and train more people.
So, the longer run that
we are talking about,
that tends to lead to a
more elastic supply curve,
in the longer run, and
then another notion here,
is that you aren't capacity constrained,
or maybe I should say,
aren't resource constrained.
Aren't resource
constrained.
So, maybe our factories are
running nowhere near capacity.
So even a small increase
of price, where it's like,
"Hey, I'm gonna just make my factories run
"a little bit more."
Or there might be a lot of
people who can help produce
who have the skills to
do, to produce that good,
so as the price goes
up, more and more people
are going to start producing that good.
Or it might be using
resources where there's
no shortage of it.
Where, as the price even
goes up incrementally,
people will just use more
and more of that resource
to provide more and more of that good.